Hello, everyone. My
name is Ryan Johnson,
and I'm a data science
advisor here at Posit.
And welcome to this
month's enterprise community meetup,
where we'll discuss another end
to end data science workflow
using Posit Team.
As a reminder,
this is a recurring event
on the last Wednesday of every
single month And its goal is
to provide the data science
community with an
overview of Posit Team,
especially for those that
may be unfamiliar with our
professional tools or maybe for
those that are looking for a
refresher or hoping to
explore new capabilities and features
within Posit Team.
Every month, we'll
cover a different topic,
and we're gonna highlight all
three tools from within Posit
Team. We have Posit
Workbench, Posit Connect,
and Posit Package Manager.
During and after
each presentation,
members of the Posit Team will
be in the chat to address any
questions you have
about our tools,
workflows, licensing questions,
and anything else you
may be curious about.
So for this month's topic,
we're gonna take a deep dive
into one of our newest open
source tools called Quarto.
Quarto is a technical
publishing system,
and in many ways it's
similar to R Markdown,
but there's no dependency
on the R programming language.
So if you are a Python,
observable, or Julia developer,
you can also create
a Quarto document.
Now if you're new to Quarto,
you are absolutely in the right
place as we are going to create
a brand new quarto document
from scratch. Using the RStudio
IDE within Posit Workbench.
We'll then show how Quarto
can be using combination with Posit
Connect to fuel some
really extremely powerful workflows.
Now before we get started,
I just want to quickly
review Posit Team,
and we'll start right here
at the top with your data
scientists and your data
analyst who will be creating
insights using Posit Workbench.
And they can choose to write
code in either R or Python,
and they have a variety
of IDEs to choose from,
including RStudio,
JupyterLabs, Jupyter
Notebooks, and VS Code.
Now for the R developers,
they may be creating
content such as shiny applications,
pins, R Markdown
or plumber APIs.
And for Python developers,
they may be creating content
such as Flask or Fast APIs,
streamlit, shiny, dash
applications, pins, Jupyter notebooks.
Now once the
content is created,
the developers will need a way
to easily share that content with viewers.
And that's where Posit
Connect comes into play.
Connect not only makes
your content shareable,
but it also gives your
team tight control over content
access and can also be
used for job scheduling,
which we're gonna
talk about today.
Finally, we have
Posit package manager.
Which does exactly as this
name implies, and that's to host,
organize, and distribute open
source R and Python packages.
Not only from the community,
but also any internally
developed R and Python packages.
Now for today's workflow,
we're going to use the
rstudio IDE from within Posit workbench
to extract and save some
data as a pin. And then we'll
create some insights from
that pinned data using quarto,
which will then publish to Posit Connect
and then run it on a schedule.
So to get started,
let's first talk about the
data we'll be analyzing today.
And I thought it might be
interesting to extract some r
package download data from
within Posit package manager.
And we can do this via
an experimental API from within package manager,
which can be used to
gather lots of great information
including package
download metrics.
So this is great for
auditing purposes,
or maybe you're just curious to
know how popular is a certain
package from within your
instance of Posit package manager.
For example, here's some
example data down here.
Of what can be gleaned from
the package manager API.
On the left hand, we can see
the r package name in this case ggplot2.
And then the number of
downloads of this package on a
specific day.
Now this data is
constantly updating.
People continue to download
packages from Posit package manager.
So one of the goals for
today is to automate the data
extraction and
visualization steps,
so that our final reports will
reflect the latest and greatest data.
And that brings us to
quarto. So for today's demo,
we're going to create
two quarto documents.
One will be for gathering,
processing, and then
saving our data.
This is often referred to as
an ETL or extract transform load workflow.
The other quarto document will
be to generate a report with
tables and plots to
visualize our results.
But what exactly is quarto?
Well, quarto, first and
foremost, is an open source
tool. So if you have a
computer and you have Internet access,
you can create a
quarto document.
It's perfect for scientific
and technical publishing
and can really be thought as
like a next generation of r
markdown. Or our way of
bringing our mark down to everyone.
And since there's no dependency
on the r programming language,
you can create a Quarto document
if you're an r developer,
Python, Julia, or
Observable programmer.
You can also create quarto
documents in whatever
environment is most comfortable for
you, including vs code,
RStudio, which is
where we'll be today,
JupyterLab or any text editor.
And you can also create a
variety of content including
articles, reports,
presentations, websites, blogs,
and books in a variety of
formats, including HTML, PDF,
Microsoft Word,
epub, and lots more.
So let's review our workflow
for today. So we're going to
draw in package download
data from POSit package
manager's API,
and we're going to pin that
data to POSit connect using quarto.
We'll then show you how to
schedule this quarto document
to run using Posit Connect,
which will automatically update
the pinned data.
Finally,
we'll create a second
quarto document for visualizing our
package download metrics,
which will also publish and
schedule to run on Posit
Connect. We'll also apply a
custom theme to this second
quarto document to make
it look really nice.
Now for our data, we are
going to use Posit's public package
manager here. So I
click on this link.
So this is a free hosted
service that provides standard
mirrors of popular r
and Python repositories,
including cran,
bioconductor, and PyPI.
Additionally, you can track
repository changes over time.
You can freeze repositories
to specific dates,
and install packages as pre
compiled Linux binaries.
Now this instance of package
manager is used by hundreds of
data science teams throughout the
world and will serve as a
good proxy for understanding
our package download trends.
So to get started let me
come back here to my slides.
To get started,
we're gonna show everyone how
to create a quarto document
from scratch using
the RStudio IDE.
So we're gonna go into Posit
workbench here and open up a
new RStudio session and then create
an rstudio project for our workflow.
Alright.
So we're gonna be using our
demo environment here at Posit.
So I'll select Posit workbench.
You can see I already have
an rstudio session running,
but we're gonna create a
brand new session for today's
workflow. So I'll click
new session. Here,
I can choose my IDE's and
I'm gonna select RStudio for today.
We can give it a custom
name if we wanted to.
Now our demo environments
in a Kubernetes cluster,
which allows me to
choose various cluster options.
I'll just leave it
as default today,
but if I did have a
more computationally
intensive job, I could
choose a larger instance.
But we'll just leave it as
default and I'll hit start session.
And we'll just give this
a few seconds to boot up.
Alright. Here we are with
an our new RStudio session.
And in the top right corner,
you can see project none.
So I'm not currently
within a project.
So let's go ahead
and change that.
I'll select this option at
the top, click new project.
Now we have some options of
where we want to place this
project. It can be in a
new directory, an existing
directory, or pulling a
project from version control.
We'll select new
directory for today.
Select new project,
and I'll give this directory
a name. I'll just say demo
test, and I'll put 123 after
it. It will hit create project.
Now anytime you open
up a new project,
it will open up a
new RStudio session.
So we'll just give this
a few seconds to boot up.
Alright. So here we are within
our new RStudio project,
and you can see the name of
our project here in the top right corner.
And our first step will be
to create a blank quarto
file. Now we can do this
by clicking this new blank file
drop down right here and
we can select quarto doc.
I'm gonna give this name
of this quarto document etl for
our extract transform and load
workflow here and hit okay.
Alright.
So here we have a blank
quarto document on the left hand side
of our screen in
our source panel.
So next, with the help of
our visual markdown editor,
so you can see I'm
currently on source.
I'm gonna click on visual.
So we're gonna add our first
component to our quarto
document, and that's gonna be
the YAML. Now YAMLs are usually
found at the very top of
the quarto documents and are used
to provide various
metadata to our documents.
So let's go ahead and add
a YAML to this blank quarto doc,
and then we'll add a
title and an author.
So to add a YAML,
I'll go to this insert drop
down and all the way towards
the bottom you'll
see YAML block.
Alright. YAML has these
three dashes at the top,
three dashes at the bottom,
put my cursor right in
between and I'll start typing title
and we'll give this
title, I'll call it ETL.
We're gonna add one more
key value pair here.
I'm gonna say author,
and I'll put my name.
That's it. Now
just for right now,
we haven't added a whole lot,
but let's go ahead and
render this quarto document.
And by default, it'll use HTML.
So we can use click
on this render button,
and we'll let Quarto
work its magic.
Alright. So here's the current
state of our quarto document.
We have our title and then
the author. Nothing fancy.
So next we're gonna add some R
code. And we do this by adding
an R code chunk or a
cell to our document.
And this can be found in the
same kind of insert drop down menu.
So I'm gonna click insert code
cell, and we're gonna add an
R code chunk or code cell.
Now to save some time,
I'm actually going to copy
and paste some R code,
which I'll explain
here in a bit.
So for right now, I'm
just gonna copy off screen here.
I'm going to paste
into this code chunk.
Some
functions to load a few
packages for our workflow for
today. But again, we'll explain all
of this code here in a bit.
So next,
I'm going to copy in some
text which provides the reader with
some background information
regarding the ETL process
within this quarto
doc. So again,
I'm also gonna copy this
off-screen, and I'm going to
paste it right here
into my quarto document.
And you can see this
nicely rendered markdown text within
this visual markdown editor.
Let's go ahead and render this document
and now see what it looks like.
Alright. So we still have our
title. There's our author.
You can see some of
code and its output right underneath.
And then down here
towards the bottom,
you can see all that
text that we added.
And it's starting
to look really nice.
So let's close out of this.
Now I'm gonna add some
more code and text,
and I'm gonna explain this
code in text in a little bit.
So I'm just gonna go ahead
and paste it all in here.
And so pretty much we have
our final ETL quarto document.
And we can now publish
it to Posit connect.
So I'm gonna go ahead and
start that process now since some of
the Rcode takes a little
bit of time to run.
And while it's publishing,
we'll go back into that
quarto document and explain some of
the code in the
text that we added.
So to publish this
quarto document,
You'll see this little blue
button at the top of your
screen. This is our publishing
button. So I'll click on this.
We're gonna choose
Posit Connect,
and we're gonna publish this
document with the source code,
which is really important
for job scheduling.
Alright. So we're only
gonna publish the single ETL.qmd
file, which is what you see
over here on the left hand side.
We're gonna publish it to
our demo environment of Connect,
which we call Colorado, and
we'll just leave the title as
ETL. And I'll just go
ahead and hit publish.
And once we do that,
down here in our console,
there's gonna be this deploy tab
that opens up and this is
all running behind the
scenes. Essentially,
what's happening is that it's
capturing my environment.
It's looking to see
what packages I use,
what versions of those
packages, what R version,
what quarto version, It captures
that, sends it to connect,
connect replicates my
environment and then deploys
this quarto document.
So let's come back into
this quarto document and explain all
the code and the
text that I added.
So in this first code
chunk right up here,
we are just loading some
r packages for this analysis.
And then in a text right
here, we're essentially just,
you know, adding
some information
about what this ETLprocess
is doing. And essentially,
I'm creating two custom
functions, which will query
that Posit package manager API.
So then we use those two
functions in this following
code chunk, which starts right
here. It's a pretty big one.
Usually, two functions
that I created.
So once we create
those two functions,
basically,
what we're gonna be doing
is using those two functions to
either package download
metrics for three packages.
We have ggplot2,
dplyr, and shiny.
This first code chunk right here
is going to get the total
downloads over the last thirty
days for each of those packages
and then come binds it into
a single data frame or a tibble,
and then it will
print the results.
And then this last
codechunk. It's already done publishing.
We'll come back here. And
this next code chunk right here,
we're gonna get similar data,
but instead we're going to
get the total downloads per day
over that same time frame,
the same thirty days.
For ggplot2, dplyr, shiny,
and then we're going to print
just the first ten rows of
that resulting data frame.
Finally,
we take the package down the
results and we're going to pin
them to Posit Connect. Alright.
That's all done right
here in this code chunk.
Now for those that are
new to the Pins package,
this is a very easy
two step process.
We first register Our pin board,
which in this case is
Posit Connect using the board_connect function,
and then we'll write two
data sets as pins to Posit
Connect using the
pin_write function.
And that's pretty much it.
So here is the published
quarto document now on Posit connect.
But I'd first like to show
you what the two pinned datasets
look like on the Posit connect server. So
let me open up a new tab here.
Oh, I guess,
duplicate this one.
I'm gonna come back to
the content on our connect
instance. And here are those two
pins that we just pinned to
Posit connect. So I'll
click on this first one.
And at the very top, Alright.
You can see the name of the
pin followed by a link to download
the data directly.
Next,
there is an r code snippet
that gives it users instructions for
how to read this pin
into their workflows.
And finally, we can see a
paginated preview of the pinned data.
Alright. Now let's switch back
over to our Posit or sorry,
our quarto document that we
just published to Posit Connect.
Now as a publisher, I not
only have control over who has
access to this document, but
I could also schedule all the
code to run on a
recurring schedule.
Now since the data
we're working with,
this package download data,
Since it updates daily, let's
set this set this document to
run every single morning at seven AM.
So to do this,
I'll first click on the
schedule tab right over here,
and we'll select the box
to schedule output for default.
So next,
you can choose your time zone
and then the start date and
time. Now we're gonna set this
to run every day at seven AM,
so let's move the
time to seven AM,
and we're gonna choose daily,
which is already selected.
Alright. So essentially,
now this will run every
single morning at seven AM.
This way,
the Pinned data sets
will remain updated without any
manual intervention,
and you can essentially
set it and forget it.
You'll also see two boxes
down here at the bottom.
So that first one means that
the report you see on your left
will be updated and republished
every time the document runs.
And the second box right down
here is to send an email to
users letting them know
the document was rerun.
Now we are going to
create a second quarto document right
now and we're actually
gonna demo this feature.
Alrighty.
So let's go ahead back
into Posit workbench.
I'm gonna close out
of this ETL script.
And we're gonna create another
quarto report or a quarto document.
So
gonna close out of this. I
will select new blank file
to record to a doc.
Now I'm gonna call
this document boring
report and hit okay.
Now I'm first going to create
a YAML just like we did before.
I'm gonna add a title
and an author. And again,
we'll use the visual markdown
editor to help us out here.
So I go to insert, scroll
down to YAML, add a title
and I'll call this
boring report.
You'll see why it's
boring here in a second.
And then I'll have author,
and I'm gonna add my name.
So next, I'm gonna copy in some
code to load a few r packages.
So let me first go ahead and
create a code chunk or code cell.
And then I'm going to add
in some code right here. We're
gonna load in two packages.
We have the pins package and
also the tidyverse package.
So after that, we're gonna add
in a little bit of text here,
which is just kind of
introducing all of our readers
to this report.
So I'm just copying and pasting this
off screen for the sake of time.
Alright. And now I'm gonna go
copy in some more code here,
and the first code chunk
is basically going to read
in that pinned data.
So if you remember when we
looked at that pin on PositConnect,
it actually included some r
code snippets to draw in those
pins into our workflows.
So I'm gonna go ahead
and copy that code.
Let me first actually
give this a title. Here,
which we're gonna
have with two hashes.
I'll say package
download metrics.
Add in a new code cell.
And I'm going to paste
in this code. So again,
we first register
our pin board,
which this case
is Posit Connect.
And then we're going to read
in those two pinned datasets.
Now finally, I'm going
to add two code chunks.
The first is going to print,
alright, that first pin,
this one right here.
It's just gonna print kind of the raw
data which is gonna be a data frame.
The second,
we're actually gonna create a
plot using the ggplot2 package.
And I'll look at the
same download over the same data
over the last thirty day window
so we can kind of visualize
some trends in our
package download metrics.
So let me go ahead
and grab that code.
I'll first add a
code chunk here.
And again this first one is
just going to print the results
or print that first
pin dataset right there.
Then I'm gonna add
another code cell,
and this is going
to create a plot.
Again, using the
ggplot2 package.
So let's go ahead and render
this quarter to see what it
currently looks like. And again,
this is our boring report.
So I'll render this and we'll
give it a few seconds to run.
Alright. So it's almost done.
And here we go. So this is
our final HTML boring report.
You can see there is my name.
And then we have our code
and again if there's any output
from that code, whether
it be a table, a plot,
or just some text.
It'll show up directly
underneath that code chunk.
We have some of the text
that we added right here.
Alright. And then we have
our package download metrics.
So this is where we
connected to our Posit connect instance
and then read those two pins.
This first code chunk, all it
does is just print the first pin,
so you can see those three
packages and how many downloads
over the last thirty days.
And then the second code chunk
right here, it creates a plot.
This is a pretty good
looking plot. Alright.
We're looking at trends of
those three packages over time,
which is on the x axis,
downloads along the y axis.
So this report, you know,
it we created it certainly gets
the job done. But it's kinda
bland and certainly could use
some sprucing up. Also, it
could be really nice to
add some custom theming to our
quarto document, that includes
our companies, colors, and logo.
And, yeah,
we wanna create something that
would really impress our leadership.
So to get started, I'm actually
gonna come back here to Posit Workbench.
And I'm going to download
a custom Posit format that I
created and is now
hosted on GitHub.
And that's what you're
seeing right here.
I did this just a few days ago,
and this is a simple
Posit quarto theme.
Now if you're ever curious
about how to create your own
theme or template,
the Quarto website is has
some great documentation for this.
So here we have for custom
HTML themes, and also for creating
customized templates for
your workflows for your team.
So coming back to this custom
theme I created on GitHub,
included some instructions
for how to use it.
So I'm gonna copy this code.
I'm gonna come back
into Posit workbench.
And open up my
console down here.
And within the terminal
tab right here,
I'm going to paste that
command and we'll hit enter.
And we'll basically just
follow the instructions.
The first thing to ask, do
you trust the authors? Well,
the author is me,
so I certainly trust myself.
I'll say y for yes. And then
we can give this template.
It's gonna be into a directory,
so we can give that directory
a name. I'll just say,
Posit-theme and hit enter.
Now if you look in
our files directory right down here,
you'll see this
Posit theme folder.
Now within this new directory,
let me click into it.
It includes a template quarto document,
which is shown right here, just
posit-theme.qmd.
And it also includes an
example HTML output file,
which is right here.
So if I click on this and
view in my web browser,
Here is what that
quarto theme looks like,
and it looks pretty
nice. You see,
we have a nice logo at
the top of the screen.
All the headers and the
text and the links basically reflect
Posit colors that we
use for our company.
And so this is kind of the
template we wanna use for our report.
So let's go ahead and open
up this posit theme template right here.
And I'm currently viewing
it in the source view.
So I'm going to actually
delete pretty much all of the
placeholder text right here.
I'm gonna come into
my boring report.
I'm gonna click on source
and I'm just going to copy
everything from
our boring report,
copy and paste it
into our nice report.
And we'll select the visual
markdown editor again.
Alright. Let's just go ahead
and render this posit theme,
this custom theme report
and see what it looks like.
Alright. So here is now our
themed report. So again,
you can see the logo.
The headers look really great.
It's starting to look
pretty good. Alright.
The text looks good.
Got a lot of code.
We got a lot kind of a
basically kinda noise here.
Like, do we really need
to see this? You know,
we can probably really
spruce this up a little bit.
And also the plot while
still a good looking plot.
You know, the colors are
the generic ggplot2 colors.
Maybe we can have those
reflect Posit colors.
So to improve the look
of this quarto document,
I'm gonna close out of this.
Let's first add a custom
posit color palette.
And we're gonna do this
using a package called rcolorbrewers.
Let me go ahead and first
load that into my environment.
Make my screen a
little bit bigger here.
So using a library function, run
Rcolorbrewer.
And we're gonna add that pallet
directly underneath here.
So I'm gonna copy
this off screen.
Come back here into this r code
and I'm gonna paste it right in
there. So this is all the
code we need to create a posit
themed color palette,
which we're gonna use for our
plot and also for our table.
So let's come back down here.
We have our pinned
read r code chunk, and then
we had this code chunk,
which as we know just
printed the raw data frame.
It did not look very good.
So let's convert this
printed text output,
and we're going to basically make
it a table and I'm gonna
add some Posit themed coloring.
To do this, we're gonna use
a package called GT. So let's
first load that package
at the very top,
and I'm gonna copy in the
code to create a GT table,
and we'll run it here so you
can see the output. So I'll first
run library to load the
GT package. I'm gonna run this
code chunk here within
Posit workbench.
Alright. We'll come
back down here.
Let's read in those
pinned datasets.
And now I'm gonna
come in right here.
I'm gonna replace this
text with a GT table.
And if you've never
used GT tables before,
they are so much fun,
create really nice tables.
So I'm gonna paste in all
the code, and let's run it.
And here is now what
our table looks like,
which looks a whole lot nicer
than just that raw dataframe text.
Finally,
let's change the look of our
ggplot to include our posit colors,
and we'll also tweak the look
by adding a minimal theme and
customizing the title
and the labels as well.
So I'm just gonna copy
this code off screen, come back
here, and I'm gonna
replace this text
with some more ggplot text,
and let me run this so you
can see it here within quarto.
There we go. So you see
some nice posit colored
lines right here.
And this is already starting
to look a lot better.
Let's go ahead and render
it and see the current
state of this quarto document.
Alright.
Starting
to look pretty good.
We still have our posit theme.
Scroll down here to our table,
so that looks really nice and
then we'll scroll down here to
our plot and that also
looks really nice.
Now it looks pretty good. But
since most of our viewers of
our document won't be really
interested in the code,
let's go ahead and hide all
the code and any kind of messages
from the final HTML output.
So let me close out of this.
I'm gonna scroll back up to my
quote to a document at the very
top in our YAML.
So we're gonna add
a few things here.
I'm gonna add an execute key,
and we're gonna apply
some code chunk options,
which will basically apply
to all the code chunks in the
document So I first want to
hide all the code from the
output by setting echo to false.
And then we'll hide any
warning messages by setting warning to
false as well. Alright. I think
this is gonna look pretty good.
Let's go ahead. I'll save it.
Render this final
quarto document.
And here we go. So now
we're not seeing any of the code.
We're only seeing the output,
the tables, and the plots.
Alright. So we can see
our nice table right here,
which again is looking
at those three packages.
And total downloads over
the past thirty days,
and here we look at those
same three packages every single day
their download metrics
for the past thirty days.
Alright. This is
a great report.
So now that we have
this final report,
let's go ahead and publish it to
Posit Connect just like we did before.
So I'll click on that
blue publish button here within Workbench.
Select Connect.
We're gonna publish this
document with the source code
since we want to schedule
it to run just like before.
We're gonna publish it to
our same demo environment in Colorado.
Here's all the files and
some of the dependencies needed for
that custom theme, and we'll leave
the title as posit theme as well.
So again,
anytime you publish from within your
RStudio IDE using this blue button,
the next thing will happen will
be this deploy tab. And again, essentially,
what's happening is RStudio
is capturing my environment,
and you can see some of the
logs here, it'll print out, you know,
certain packages that are
needed for this quarto document
and the associated versions.
So we'll just give this a
few seconds to run and then we'll
come back together once
it's all published.
Okay. Just a few more seconds.
It's now rendering the quarto
document. It's the last step.
Running all those various code
chunks. There's the output file.
And
There we go.
And now here is our final
report. Now hosted publish to Posit Connect.
And so once it's here, again,
the main advantage is you
have tight control as a publisher
over who has access to this
doc. So for example, if I
wanted to define
specific users or groups,
I can define them right here.
So if I wanted to
share this with Rachael, for example,
I most certainly could. And
now we would be the only two
people here at Posit that would
have access to this quarto
document, this report.
I could alternatively select
this middle option right here
and basically have all
users login required.
So as long as you can
log in to Posit Connect,
you can view this content
that would essentially open this up
to all Posit employees.
So next we'll want to make
sure that this quarto document is
scheduled to rerun so that it
reads in that new pinned dataset,
which again is being updated
every single day at seven AM.
And it updates this report
so that these numbers reflect,
you know, those new package
data every single day.
So let's set it to rerun
basically daily at, let's just
say noon every single day.
And we'll go through the
same workflow. I'll click on schedule,
schedule output for default,
choose your time zone
and I'm gonna select noon
and we'll run this
every single day.
Now this time,
we're also gonna send an
emailed notification to our
teammates to let them know the
report was run. So to do this,
we select this box right
here at the bottom,
and we can add
our either collaborators or viewers,
which we assign previously,
so that was Rachael.
Or I can come in here and
I can add Rachael directly for example.
And so once we
do this, Rachael, basically, every
single day around noon,
she'll get an email with a
direct link to this report so
that she can view the latest
package download metrics.
And if we switch back
to my slides here,
I actually have an example
of what one of those emailed
reports looks like.
So you can see here that
it's sent directly by Posit Connect
with me as this Sender,
and it links to the latest
versions of the report.
The subject line you see
up here at the top is also
customizable, and it also a
tab is an HTML version of the
quarto report directly
to this email.
Alright. And so with that,
we have come to the end
of our workflow for today.
Now I hope everyone found
this month's demo helpful.
And we'd love to chat more
about Posit. eam, quarto, pins,
job scheduling,
or anything else.
So feel free to stick around
and we'll have a few Posit
folks available to answer
any questions you have.
Thanks everyone for joining,
and I hope and I look
forward to seeing everyone again next month.
Thank you so much for
the great demo, Ryan,
and Thank you everybody
for joining us today.
I see there's already been a
few great questions in the chat.
We are gonna do things a
little bit differently than the last
two months where we're gonna
try and answer questions live
instead of just in the chat
as well. So as a reminder,
there's also a slide link open
for anonymous questions, and so that's at
pos.it/demo-questions,
and I'll put
that here in the chat
in another second here too.
But we're gonna send you over to
another platform for the q & a,
and it should automatically
send you there from YouTube
right now. But thank you again,
and have a great
rest of the day.
We'll see you over in the q & a.